um well fortune you went on a road trip
as well right i did yeah yeah i uh my
partner and i went
on a road trip uh to arizona at a show
out there
and there she is uh and we were driving
you have to go through the desert to get
to
phoenix because we were not ready to fly
during these times yeah and i spot these
these two big vans on the side of the
interstate like broken down and
and there's there's like like i said
middle of nowhere there's only like a
prison and that's
it and i see this like super buff dude
he's got a man bun he's shirtless and he
has these crazy black and white striped
pants on and i'm like did some hot guy
escape from prison what's happening
and i can't see his face he's in the van
trying to fix
the um the van and we just
passed by like five seconds and i turned
to my partner and i'm like
man bun shirtless ripped crazy pants
i was like i think that was jason momoa
and we got to a gas station like 30
minutes later i'm like i'm just gonna
look at his insta story if anything
happens to a celebrity they
instastory it and uh and there he was on
the side of the road it was jason momoa
shirtless
man bun crazy pants he's like my man
broke down in the desert
and i posted it on and every straight
woman alive was like
why didn't you stop and i'm like
what am i going to do for jason momoa
like spit in his gas tank and make his
van start
like i can't help him out he was fine he
he was on the road like 30 minutes later
but i
ladies spotted jason momoa from
just his
an body yeah so it's i mean it's
spottable
it's like you know it was a mirage yes
not many people look like that so i
think that's why
they don't just come out like that
generally
[Music]
you